episode 4 of the falcon and the winter
soldier the whole world is watching
featured some shocking twists and turns
and some intriguing revelations
after a couple of installments that set
the stage it's fair to say that the show
has now hit its stride
here's how it all went down the kickoff
the whole world is watching the falcon
and the winter soldier
opened with a flashback to bucky's time
in wakanda six years ago
he's shown working with io to overcome
his verbal triggers that caused him to
become the bloodthirsty winter soldier
signifying his rebirth as the white
dwarf
[Music]
with time will and the resources the
winter soldier programming was removed
from your la carotene fur
we're then brought back to the present
where the dora melange member tells
bucky he has eight hours left before she
and her forces come to take
zemo into custody after all in captain
america civil war zemo did kill king
tachaka
single-handedly dividing the avengers
and therefore weakening earth's best
defense against sanos
as expected later in the episode the
dora melange arrive and attempt to
apprehend
zemo but they're unsuccessful thanks to
the unnecessary intervention of john
walker a scuffle in shoes between him
sam and bucky against io and her
soldiers providing the baron with the
prime
opportunity to escape through the sewers
by the time the credits roll
zemo remains at large as our heroes
continue their efforts to track down
carly morguntho
and her companions the flagsmash's plans
wind up facing some unforeseen
complications for one they learn that
the governments of the world plan to
tighten their borders in response to the
flag smashers attacks
which of course is the exact opposite of
what they want not only that but morale
is also incredibly low as the group
puts to rest their beloved mamadonia who
inspired the basic tenets of their
movement
the flag smasher's misfortune doesn't
end there as zemo deals them their
biggest blow
following an encounter with sam and
company cardi runs right into the baron
who doesn't hesitate to shoot her at
point-blank range wounded she drops the
remaining vials of super soldier serum
key resources to expand her army
prompting the fervently anti-super
soldiers emo to smash nearly all of them
into the concrete
finally with the power broker still hot
on the group's heels the episode ends
with one of carly's closest confidants
being brutally murdered in the streets
of latvia
driving home just how bad off the flag
smashers are at this point in the story
surely the flag smashers will try to
regroup in the next two episodes but
they've never been
more vulnerable now that they're reeling
and desperate who knows how far they'll
go to try and escalate their campaign
while it may seem like the beginning of
the end for the group they definitely
will not go quietly
even in the face of multiple setbacks
cardi morgenthu has a handful of tricks
up her sleeve to keep the flag smashers
cause alive
one such trick involves her connection
to sam wilson which began at their first
face-to-face conversation
at marmadonia's memorial though they're
pitted against one another
the two actually realize they agree on
many points they both believe that the
current way of the world isn't working
and needs correction in order to save
lives their chat reveals an interesting
dick to me
but only one of them is framed as a hero
sam being an avenger and part of the
united states military
very much wants to help the entire world
but he can't bring himself to rise up
against the systems that work against
him
his sister and countless others in their
position meanwhile kali operates from
the perspective of an outsider who has
been taken advantage of and wants to
make an active change in the world
however her willingness to spill
innocent blood to achieve her goals
understandably brands her and her
acolytes as terrorists
in the closing moments of the whole
world is watching carly extends the
olive branch to sam
offering him the opportunity to join the
flag smashers he doesn't outright refuse
or accept her offer
though it seems unlikely he'll take her
up on it she did after all threatened to
hurt his sister and his nephews if he
refused the invitation to meet
even still sam's goals seem to be
bringing this conflict to a peaceful
conclusion
just how or if he'll be able to do that
remains to be seen
unsurprisingly sam bucky and zemo's
highly eventful trip to mad report last
week wasn't without its consequences
the trio failed to keep a low profile
drawing the expedition to the sketchy
locale
especially after zemo killed dr nagel
the man behind the return of the super
soldier serum and the direct associate
of the power broker
as sharon carter explained to sam the
mysterious figure is not at all happy
with their intervention
and as a result the entire region is
about to fall into a state of chaos
at this point the power broker has yet
to make a physical appearance in the
show
even though they have played a key role
throughout it with their pursuit of the
flag smashes so far unsuccessful
and that one of their most important
scientific minds lacking a pulse
surely the power broker will have to
make their presence felt through more
than just threatening text messages and
word of mouth
not only that but given her role in sam
bucky and zemo's plan
one can only hope that the already on
the run sharon doesn't too become
ensnared in the power broker's quest for
vengeance
that is of course unless she's got a
deeper connection to the power broker
than any other allies might suspect
a few days after episode 3 of the falcon
and the winter soldier aired
sharon carter actress emily van camp
spoke with variety
and addressed the fan theory that her
character might in fact
be the power broker herself she told the
magazine
i mean the power broker could be anybody
also there are several characters that
have yet to be seen so i mean i can't
say anything
while her response is far from
surprising it's still worth wondering
just what else sharon might be hiding
from us
as she goes about her shady business in
madrid could she be the mysterious
antagonist that's been chasing after the
flag smashers for stealing the serum why
she still be secretly working for shield
or is this just a whole lot of
speculation that will ultimately lead to
nothing
we'll find out over the next two weeks
of course it wouldn't be an episode of
the falcon in the winter soldier without
an
update on no one's favorite captain
america john walker
both he and the ma battlestar huskins
reunite with sam bucky and zemo
immediately commandeering the mission
and scolding them for releasing zemo
from prison
man let's be clear shield or no shield
the only thing you're running in here is
your mouth
they then botched sam's hopes of
communicating peacefully with carly
leading the already insecure walker to
find the thing he wanted most but the
last thing he needed
a vial of super soldier serum much like
his comic book counterpart the mcu's
john walker takes the enhancement
though he does so off-screen and wastes
little time putting it to good use
he and hoskins get back to hunting the
flag smashers and hoskins ends up
captured
moments later a battle breaks out where
sam and john walker take on a handful of
flax smashers
this allows hoskins time to break free
of his bonds and meet his demise at the
hands of cardi morgenthu while trying to
protect walker from her attack
in sense of the sudden death of his
partner walker loses it and goes into a
blind rage
directed at anyone he can get his hands
on even though carly is his main target
walker finds and slaughters one of her
fellow flag smashers with his shield
a crowd assembles with cell phones in
hand documenting the murder needless to
say
walker will probably get a lot fewer
autograph requests now
long time fans of the marvel comics
probably figured something like this
would be coming
walker's aggression always
differentiated him from steve rogers
and eventually resulted in him moving
away from the identity of captain
america
and taking on a different superpowered
code name us agent
just how the us government sam and bucky
will respond to this display of violence
and to walker's new and hinged
personality will undoubtedly be the
highlights of next week's episode
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the falcon and the winter soldier are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and to
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you